I think one of the surprising things
that like it's weird a lot of times you
know certain reviewers and start now
let's don't like to talk about too much
about the intent behind the game or like
what's like the developer what it means
for the developer but kind of hard to
separate the story of guerrilla games
from horizon zero dawn mainly because
the only thing they've done before is
this drab action shooter or franchise
they did have a game before kill zone
but I deserting anything they've done
well certainly ever since their first
game all it's all killed out here in
like 12 years or so yeah yeah and now
you know after three kill zones and then
Killzone shadow fall which is pretty
much just showing off the attack of the
ps4 they're here was horizon zero dawn
which you know it's an amalgamation with
a few different kinds of games action
RPG open world but it's cool they made
the jump pretty gracefully I based on my
feelings about the evolution of Killzone
I didn't care about this game at all
yeah I didn't even plan on reviewing it
I started had to pick it up due to
circumstances I was so pleasantly
surprised and it has totally overwritten
my perception of guerrilla games like
I'd kill zone is like that's history I
don't even I can't even fact that in and
yeah this is a shellshock nam 67 ya dumb
name um but yeah it brought they it is
food because like this story seems it's
a weird thing like I'm so we're going to
talk again in a few minutes about to
open world games in general and whether
they're kind of whether the genre is
just this big amorphous blob right now I
think horizons up some cool things to
set it apart and then you know we have
breath on the wild on the horizon and
last year and a few of them but i just
spent on the horizon i can understand it
way too much that was accidental that
time I yeah it is impressive as hell
that they could have made this jump so
well and introduce their own ideas into
the fray at the same time I don't know
I'm what we wanna get into other
developers but like did you play it kill
them at all Kelly barely yeah you like
shooters a lot I do they were pretty
boring shooters yeah I mean as far as
your shooters go i play a lot of them
there was nothing really to draw me in
to kill zone so I barely touched it yet
um yeah i mean just I just going from
first person shooter too sir
person action alone we're disregarding
everything else about horizon is a big
jump to me it like is impressive enough
to me like oh that's a completely
different mindset different level design
different everything yeah it seems like
they definitely establish themselves
here with a new like show that they can
do in a one-trick pony so to speak so
guerrilla games for all intents purchase
looks like they're doing well and we
want to talk about other developers
there might be like hot right now for
lack of a better term at the present
time or even developers that we like
have done no wrong it would seem I
wanted to go first I think blizzard
entertainment consistently does the same
thing I think for the most part I think
over washed their first big shooter was
a huge success it's one of my favorite
shooters ever now one of my favorite
games last year Blizzard has this
uncanny ability to understand what makes
a genre great and kind of boil it down
to its maybe not bare essentials but
boil it down to its essence and then you
know the low thing is up from there
overwatch itself is just like great teen
shooter great tactics just a character
is how they interplay with each other i
actually think i've talked about it
before the world-building of overwatch
despite the fact it's not right in your
face is someone favor in a game in
recent memory of course you know they
went from you know like start with
Warcraft and I jump to starcraft of to
RTS properties you have world of
warcraft which shows no signs of slowing
down in the MMO space or I mean show
signs of slowing down but it's still
pretty huge for being how many years old
14 oh yeah we're like 13 years old if
that's crazy and then they still have
how many subscribers million Michael
millions of people in Azeroth every day
they got that but those pandas now i'm
not paying extension and i like diablo 3
despite the fact that a lot of people
don't Eric T is probably like throwing
up right now but i really like diablo 3
that's one of my favorite games i
realize that it is skewed a lot of what
made the elbow too good but they could
do an action RPG like no other and
they've every time they jump John Rose
like who knows what would happen with
Titan but that would've been an MMO as
well so you know they for all intents
persons are doing really well mm-hmm I
don't know Pete you have a developer in
mind that you think is kind of
talked about it yesterday now I know
like you mention a few like Cal you
mentioned a fulbright company yeah indie
space yeah as far as Indies go I've gone
home as one of my favorite games and
that's the reason I want to play Tacoma
like aside from everything that I know
about to come on which isn't actually
that much I know the setting and kind of
like what it's like space adventure
thing but I will play it simply because
it's full bright and I know that they do
a good job and now that Mina Freeman
works at fulbright I really liked how do
you do it which is like this little
experimental like flash I think game
that she did now that she does level
design over there I have even more
incentive to to be interested in tacoma
even without knowing that much so that's
kind of aside from triple-a stuff that
they're the ones I'm keeping my eye on
for now ya gone home was great I loved
every second of it I haven't replayed it
I don't think since I finished it but
Tacoma I'm hoping will scratch that itch
especially you know set on a space
station looks kind of like a system
shock vibes almost not that it's the
first person sim shooter like prey is
but I'm really looking forward to Tacoma
and actually that against that way
Arkane Studios since they really
dishonored in 2012 seems like they just
been nailing I mean hun or two is the
only other game and now they have prey
which looks fantastic it looks right up
my alley it's more open world and
dishonored it's sci-fi horror game so so
it goes hold on prey yes s'okay away for
it and I feel like arcane for several
reasons you know they're bringing back
that first person immersive sim storage
urban shooter that you know like System
Shock deus ex back in the day with
origin systems and Looking Glass Studios
they were pioneering it but didn't know
it catch on because you have to be
pretty patient to play those kind of
games I don't think that was a time
before people realize how intelligent
games could be with their son and heir
lies what I'm play to do man was it yeah
Jim yeah which is nothing wrong with
that no I ya know I'm not going today no
I know yeah it was like excuse me
Studios like continuously impressing me
like this one or two I playing through
it for the second time on and off right
now and I'm loving it and I'm pretty
excited to see what they do with pray
and see now they're like rap colantonio
that's a few things man yes yeah he's
out he's out of prey and elite want to
say to me somehow you find a way to fit
and yeah in general if like then with
Harvey Smith is the head of Dishonored
why do used to throw me off like that I
keep all of you that is he's not Spanish
like I'm applying in action but anyway
it's a like our Coentrao kind of always
just you know seems like they can do no
wrong right now but something that holds
up on Mase it's when prey releases I
don't know what other developers are
there like that are always like I feel
like rockstar it's me Alicia jump from
jig to 23 was pretty significant again
did someone say naughty dog it looks
like foam knuckles studies you know i'm
sure i'll ever arguing over Naughty Dog
I think okay I was going to say naughty
dog I don't dislike anything except for
like uncharted one I mean they were
rather than jumping genres like
guerrilla games did we were just talking
about you can look at Naughty Dog and
see this gradual logical evolution nice
i was crash bandicoot the third person
like bare bones third person platformer
action game on the first play statement
uncharted and there you go and then
connects texture which is more the
evolution of that third person shooter
and mac mechanics in it in wider world
and you go to uncharted it's like grand
adventure with set pieces by the time
you get to uncharted 3 of the last of us
right around the corner and so much more
bleak and much more story driven but you
know a lovely person adventure and kind
of like shooting mechanics survival
mechanics unshowered four rolls around
some jamoke at gamespot gave it a 10 out
of 10 but it's a fantastic game in its
own right thigh that was me i really
like skin here that jointly i think
everybody should play on charter for for
various reasons and you can read my
review if you want to it's up on the
site go talk about you do know and yeah
it's updated with lots legacy on the
ride maybe you should play on chat for
if you haven't finished it did you plan
charter for Kelly mm-hmm I've never
played an uncharted Illinois anything
interesting I was like you until a few
months ago yeah for is that great place
to start really yep for real all day and
I've I played like 10 minutes of one
when it first came out I was like screw
this [ __ ] oh the f MA put it in the day
and then I played uncharted 4 need the f
although the ESC i am placing a dollar
inside the f-bomb we'll figure out what
to do the money later on but it is in
there we can buy ourselves look nice
pizza anyway china for is great because
it you don't really need all the history
of the characters of the games ok it
tells us compelling strange desire
towards friendly uh yeah Bucky bits on
Twitch said valve ? earlier a little bit
earlier I mean I really valve is so
different than what it used to be now
yeah so eSports focused and very
generous dota 2 and I'm sure one I know
they have and then all their proprietary
stuff and their hardware to boot but I'm
sure they have a lot of that they're
working on but who knows what it is yeah
I'm not quite on topic but kind of
similar discussion about developer that
went from perhaps their relevance to
utter relevance is psionics yeah I mean
rocket don't need to tell you guys a
story of rocket League it's incredible
first version of that game that came out
in like two thousand eight or nine super
super burger and acrobatic supersonic
acrobatic rocket-powered battle cars
yeah we need a jinx jar who that game
was it didn't have legs and deleted that
God but what about what about rocket
League does it rocket League has so many
legs it's got wheels the sub definitely
not a joke we're done when was that
rocket what about losing a dollar
supersonic acrobatic rocket problematic
college battle cars I'll not have one
oculi has wheels has NOS it has machine
gun to come out of the hood of the cars
in the dlc which is up cup no I'm just
kidding oh my god but you do have that
thing with the splendid splinter so the
weapon plunger that's the word played
much of the know mode with although i
got i get so sick of that nitrous dan
that's the ugliest car ever that's
really i'm a muffin moon a person you
would be we boo oh yeah you're oh yeah
oh yeah a disabled mango once and yeah
okay um well what did overs we have here
i mentioned that ya rockstar we kind of
got into briefly I have one I want to
bring up to you because I'm sure you
have an opinion about it from software i
think most things from software does
it's just great I mean that
they're a little more relevant know
Yoram the giant that's where the
beginning we are you talking about yes I
almost swear don't know like so where's
the beginning of the show we showed this
your um the giant giveaway I don't feel
like picking it back up but it's
relevant because Dark Souls 3 has DLC
incoming Eric Tay would know when it's
about a month or two away kind of amid
the spring release schedule everything
from does is some sort of excellent I
gave Dark Souls 3 and 8 out of 10 i felt
like it got a little repetitive in the
late game and the bosses stop being
interesting same problem having neo
actually but i really like both neo and
Dark Souls 3 but blood-borne is one of
my favorite games and anything from
others of my footage I think anything
from software does is just in general
I'd expect it to be fantastic and they
haven't let me down yet so I don't have
any reason to expect they might you
should play some of their old games well
right like before demon's souls what was
a little kingdom something kingdom Oh
Kingsfield Kingsfield series they were
and it looks like Ultima Underworld
first person like RPGs Tim yeah am i
right dungeon crawler yeah yeah and of
course they made a lot of armored core
games which were very hit or miss ya but
since demon souls feel like they've yeah
now that more or less speaking of
someone that used to be kind of so-so
with joe danger joe Danger Danger Danger
hello again it's kind of a young xenon
rose with no man's sky a contentious
game of 2016 some people got what they
wanted some people did not some people
felt like promises were broken some
people felt like marketing led them
astray but if I could her love it no
man's sky was very different from joe
Danger hello games previous series yeah
people what's your thoughts on the jumps
they made they took away motorcycle yeah
there you go mr. go ahead Joe well I
wrote plated Joe the whole time yeah
obviously the expanded is huge you know
universe with all these I guess was a
galaxy galaxy with all these planets and
star systems and all those great stuff
it's just like joe Danger was like
here's a motorcycle you're gonna Ram up
go off and jump get some points like
this is not that
I I think you defend no man's got more
than a lot of people yeah I'll defend it
do it to near death near death near that
I won't die for whenever I think about
no man's guy thing about that video
really probably like the janky Jurassic
Park yeah yeah we all did it I couldn't
I I found I couldn't find enough
substance to know my sky grant i only
play for four hours but i couldn't find
enough can i ask you where you played it
at home by yourself their killer they're
bothering you touch an inside joke no
not at the time if my former roommates
who made things not enjoyable sometimes
the watching Eric I hate watching no I
was pointing at home and uh yeah for
about four hours a night and then oh and
then I left for a trip for work and then
I never came back to it afterward yeah
so I immerse myself for like a week
straight just like not moving I had the
perfect [ __ ] groove in the couch I mean
I literally spent as much time as i cud
had everything yeah why's my bike groove
moanin yeah I spent much time i could
buy myself playing it you me that's bad
team yeah like I really had to immerse
myself anything bad you know and I
really just kind of that's what did it
for me like if you look at it for like a
bullet point like a checklist kind of
thing law does it do these things that
they told me it would do no it doesn't
really add up ah but kind of like
horizon I didn't really pay attention to
no man skaggs I didn't think was going
to be a game for me and kind of like
horizon I just fell into it for what it
was I thought it was actually very
impressive nope not I mean it's
different when you don't work in games i
guess but like I definitely work very
hard not to evaluate a game based on
what I expected from it like I want to
take it for what it is which is is very
different for if you're you know just
like you were really excited for this
game you saw the trailer is worth all
the hype for it and then you got
something that was different um I think
you know being on either sides of that
fence you're going to have to kind of
pins about no man's sky yeah yeah and
then I want to did want to mention a
rockstar quick I keep bringing it up
feel like everything they do is pretty
you know spot on yes table toes game was
okay yeah I'd wanted rock star game I've
never played that I always get yelled at
for its bully you ever my bullied you
never play bully oh my god my girl oh my
god I've never played boy oh my god if
you had a play bullied you white boy
tell us about bully uh they did not miss
the mark with this I take it so well
okay so the other weekend I got really
drunk and played bully which was really
fun click kept wanting to go to English
class I get driving bully people hahaha
I your rocks it kid I'm Renee that
adults haha they can take it running on
your age oh yeah something morally
Hawaii in depending on my good looking
really good yeah yeah I've got one
rocket launcher someone draw that graph
of like look terrific parabola anyway uh
yeah I mean it's you just go around you
punch people and you go to class and
kiss girls and you can kiss boys so you
know very head of its time and like play
pranks right yeah you just yeah I look
like like I did Halloween but like i
said i was super drunk I'm a writer so I
was like I can't wait to go to english
class and be smart in English um drink
responsibly and hydrogen eight not yet
but it's just like one of those I don't
even I wouldn't call it a cult David's
getting away but Davis is getting away
the permanent upper third telling you
that there's something that there's
something so like stupidly fun about it
are you out of school the whole time um
you know you can go in town you can go
on like a festival date with a girl I
couldn't figure out how to get to the
festival I tried swimming in the ocean
and it didn't work and then she dumps me
we tried swimming the edge of the
festival yeah because it was a prophet
abay Oh getting wailed on uh when we
move on from bully if you're ready is
that everything is that it up yeah
that's basically what i wanted to say
that's a rock star doesn't always
disappoint to say believe they will
heavily all genres too much but you know
they are capable like Max Payne 3 wasn't
an open-world game that was still a
fantastic third-person shooter one of my
favorite I do want to talk about someone
that
teams on the decline p that you
mentioned yesterday i have near autumn
otta on the platinum um that was what a
weird story and yeah it felt like for
years they could do no wrong like they
were just kind of like every beat was
like yes yes yes then up then a group of
muni turtle came along last year in
manhattan new york uh yeah it was I
think was Cora was the first game or
maybe turtle came first but they had a
slew of like licensed games like
transformers was apparently okay because
it didn't really reach too far and it
sort of delivered this like cooling 80s
action game but yet battles quorum by
the way the polygons review for turtles
is like the funniest review and I
beretta not Justin no I don't remember
who wrote it oh maybe it was maybe a lot
of math so it's really funny yeah go
read that yeah and they seem to be
slipping a little bit and who knows
where the buck falls when it comes to
the xbox one game dragon scale bound yes
dragged a professional who knows whose
fault that is but the story of platinum
is a bit strange at this point not to
see you know hi everything right now
it's Justin McElroy okay sounds funny
reason you see some of their failures
and then to sort of see a game like that
the big one get cancelled it is pretty
big at indication of some problems as is
the president leaving a company what
what is happening with them i don't know
i don't i don't think they're out of
great ideas like the new near is really
fun when i play in preview that girl's
outfit love it total weekend at cosplay
it if it hits all the right like what
was for me in terms of action and
presentation and that like platinum
creativity when it comes to like just
mixing that all together in something
really fascinating and fun but I you
know what else do they have right now
it's they're making a game with the
people who made final fantasy tactics
but it isn't mobile like yeah there's
all this like weird enough where I feel
like the stuff that people really want
from them is sort of like a side project
for platinum now right and I do adapt to
the market and it seems like their
reputation which is already kind of at a
low point hinges on yeah be sequel to a
cult classic yeah near which not a lot
of people played i'm looking forward to
auto model ott it's really fun for my
play the the platinum mechanics
really great but I don't know if that's
gonna be enough to like elevate them
again I mean is they clearly have the
talent in the house I don't think it's a
slide to anyone who works there we
create games for them to sort of look at
platinum this way it's just the business
decisions and the projects that are
being taken on I don't know and maybe
they're just not given the same
treatment among the teams right certain
people go to play there to develop
certain games other ones work on the
license stuff yeah yeah I don't know it
harms the reputation of company a little
bit yeah we look forward to near on
tomorrow yeah yeah I don't everybody
didn't play the original I just it's
like I want to jump into it now yeah
that there's a new one coming up did you
play drakengard 3 apparently this is
like something of a spiritual successor
wait really yeah oh cool I'd never play
dragon I haven't played that one but
that's cool but sound like anything you
might play probably not an insult I I a
dragon guard or knowing you would my
being with my plan Mike would play a wii
sports resort at least give me like ten
Doland nah you'd play wii sports resort
are just for a workout whatever all
right moving on so if we didn't mention
any developers that you think jump.john
rly well or any developers that are kind
of hot right now doing a good job with
their recent releases or any that you
are excited for let us know hit us up on
Twitter Pete Brown cali plaguey mike my
hearty and yeah leave you thoughts in
the comment below if you're watching
this on youtube
[Music]